well it's so great to start with some
good news today Raphael Warnock has
defeated Herschel Walker in the Georgia
Senate runoff this means that Democrats
will control the Senate 51-49 rather
than 50 50. this has a number of
important consequences which we are of
course going to talk about but the big
news is that it did not go the way of
Donald Trump and of Maga and of the
Herschel Walker endorsement industrial
complex wing of the Republican Party
Georgia Senate runoff election results
Warnock 51.4 Walker 48.6 now
I am with everybody in the audience in
particular many of our viewers from
around the world who look at Herschel
Walker and they say
how does this guy even have a shot in a
state like Georgia with a population
voting population in the millions how
does this guy not lose by 70 even as
deranged and ignorant as the Republican
Party electorate is in the United States
and of course that horrifies me as well
this is a guy who shouldn't even have
had a shot and yet he came within under
a hundred thousand votes in the runoff
of becoming one of 100 senators in the
United States we're not going to fix the
United States in that sense right here
in this segment so I won't dwell on that
uh too too much Democratic senator
Warnock wins Georgia runoff against
Walker reports the Associated Press and
indeed now control of the Senate will be
not only excuse me
I'm almost back from covid but not a
hundred percent uh it will be not 50 50
but it will be 51 to 49 and there are so
many reasons that that is hugely
important which I will get to but first
let's look at a couple of Clips here are
the calls from the three major networks
what does this look like Statewide well
I'll I'll let you take it from there
because I think there's some news there
that check mark is a consequence
NBC News
incumbent Democrat Rafael Warnock
Governor uh we have seen changes all
over Senator yeah we're going to
interrupt you I want to go to Jake for a
uh an announcement excellent that's
right we can now make a projection in
the final senate election of the 2022
midterm elections CNN projects the
Democratic senator Rafael Warnock will
win re-election in the Georgia Senate
runoff right now we're relying on the
Associated Press to give us these
numbers and right now the Associated
Press is just given the check mark to
Rafael Warnock he's going back to the
U.S Senate as the winner of this runoff
against Herschel Walker now we will get
back to that Fox News call because it
actually happened at sort of a very very
interesting moment now we did hear from
both candidates winner and loser alike
starting with the winner Rafael Warnock
take a quick listen
foreign
and after a
hard-fought campaign
[Applause]
or should I say campaigns
it is my honor
to utter the four most powerful words
ever spoken in a democracy
the people have spoken
very much so in Raphael Warnock actually
talking about a number of important
points including the fact that just
because he won doesn't mean there
weren't efforts at voter suppression
which by the way is very different than
saying it was rigged I know there were
some Republicans seizing on this and
saying look Republicans aren't the only
ones who say it was rigged that's not
what Warnock is saying there are those
who would look at the outcome of this
race
and saying that there's no voter
suppression in Georgia
let me Let Me Clear
just because people endured
long lines
that wrapped around buildings
some blocks long just because they
endured the rain and the cold
and all kinds of tricks in order to vote
doesn't mean that voter suppression does
not exist it simply means that you the
people have decided that your voices
will not be silent yeah and of course
there were attempts to suppress the vote
and we know what these are Georges of
epicenter of these try to reduce early
voting they did this when it came to the
period after Thanksgiving we covered it
on the award-winning bonus show of
course oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad now we
also heard from the loser
who was Herschel Walker and there was a
question as to whether Herschel Walker
would have any idea what's even going on
like how does he even give a concession
speech and he sort of did and he said
something about the numbers aren't
adding up for him we've had a tough
Journey have we not
one of the things I said is they when
they called the race I said enormous
doesn't look like they're going to add
up
right but one of the things I want to
tell all of you is you never stop
dreaming I don't want any of you to stop
dreaming I don't want any of you to stop
believing in America I want you to
believe in America and continue to
believe in the Constitution and believe
in our elected officials most of all
well that belief is slightly reinforced
by the fact that this guy fortunately is
not going to be a U.S senator continue
to pray for them because all the prayers
you've given me I felt those prayers I
want to thank apparently they were not
quite enough follow my team as well team
Herschel because they put up with a lot
and I want to thank team Marshall thank
all my donors as well because you guys
with how you have couldn't have done
what I've done yep so a sort of uh
concession speech from Herschel Walker
and then maybe the most important Point
reminding himself he's still sort of a
winner right
we all winners so we're all winners and
that's what I want to say we're all
winners and I want to say God is a good
god yep everybody won at the end of the
day everybody won at the end of the day
um Donald Trump's reaction not pleased
tweeting in of tweeting trophing of
course on Truth social truth essential
our country is in big trouble what a
mess now the importance of 5149 rather
than 50 50. because either way it would
be a democratic majority because Kamala
Harris in a 50 50 tie is the
tie-breaking vote and she still would be
the tie-breaking vote if there is a 50
50 tie in the Senate but 5149 means
Democrats don't have to negotiate a
power sharing arrangement with the
Senate minority leader Mitch McConnell
that's a great thing number two there's
no one Senator veto power okay now it's
two so at 50 50
Joe manchin alone or Kirsten Cinema
alone becomes sort of one senator
vetoers now there's no one Senator veto
power it's two but that's still a better
situation committees is the third issue
because of the current power sharing
agreement with the equal Senate split
any tie on a committee goes to a full
Senate vote now Democrats still have the
majority but if you have a committee
with 16 members and you have an eight
and eight uh split and you have an eight
to eight vote that committee vote now
has to go to the full Senate where if
it's 50 50 in comes Kamala Harris and
breaks the tie it's just going to be
much faster because having a majority on
the Committees more than likely
Democrats will have a one-seat majority
on every committee you skip that entire
dog and pony show still it's a majority
either way but it would be much more
annoying with the 50 50.
um and it just makes everything faster
and then also the subpoena issuing
process will be much stronger because
you won't really need bipartisan support
to issue subpoenas that's important and
if there were to be a supreme court
vacancy we don't know it always you just
don't know it depends on who who's the
nominee and what's the process when does
it happen but it's always better to have
more seats in the event that there is a
supreme court vacancy or even another
potential judicial vacancy so very
important Maga in shambles and we will
talk about that but first let's talk
about Laura Ingram on Fox News who had a
really bad night last night I love
reading I read every day no matter how
Iran change my schedule I never have
enough time to read all the books that I
want which is why blinkist has been such
an important part of my life for years
now our sponsor blinkist is the app that
takes thousands of non-fiction books
boils them down into an explainer that
you can read or listen to in just 15
minutes which includes all the most
important takeaways from the book with
blinkist I can absorb the essence of 15
different books in an afternoon so I can
quickly gather insights from all sorts
of perspectives make connections have
those kind of aha moments that don't
happen so easily which is why I feel
enriched when I use blinkist blinkist
also summarizes episodes of popular
podcasts into 15-minute explainers and
with the blinkist connect feature my
girlfriend and I can share one account
share books podcasts with each other
talk about them on the go and don't
forget blinkist makes the perfect
holiday gift my audience can try
blinkist free for seven days and get 25
percent off after that go to
blinkist.com Pacman the link is down
below